at a logistics Hub outside the capital
Doha ambulance staff prepare hundreds of
medical packs for use during the World
Cup they'll be sent each day to clinical
teams working at stadiums fan zones
hotels and entertainment venues
in crowded areas mobile teams of
paramedics will use golf carts scooters
and bicycles to get to patients quickly
my advice to any of the fans when you
need a healthcare please ask for the
nearest clinic
around you because there will be such a
provision easily accessible for you and
these will provide also a healthcare
free of charge because they will tackle
the Urgent Care need for for defense
cattle's Healthcare capacity has
increased significantly in the last
decade with 10 new hospitals and 16
additional Primary Health Care Centers
it has the biggest Emergency and Trauma
Center in the region and extra staff
have been hired for the World Cup
for the infrastructure we have expanded
we can accommodate a large number of the
population
in addition to the infrastructure we
have to talk about the workforce so we
have a very highly skilled Workforce
that is a multinational speaks many
languages to take care of our patients
and visitors
cattle's Emergency Services have also
expanded in recent years and include
specialist teams which airlift patients
to hospital
these two air ambulances are on call 24
hours a day seven days a week they bring
critically ill and injured patients here
to hammer General Hospital the main
Trauma Center in Qatar
in preparation for the World Cup
authorities say they've left nothing to
chance they've invested in
state-of-the-art equipment such as this
mobile field hospital if needed it can
be set up in 15 minutes they'll be one
deployed to each Stadium on Match days
if a major incident does occur medical
staff will examine patients in a blue
tent those who are critically ill will
be transferred to a red tent which
contains defibrillators and oxygen tanks
seriously ill patients will be moved to
a yellow tent and those with minor
injuries to a green one
alongside each field hospital is a
command center from where authorities
can coordinate an emergency response
Health leaders have prepared for all
eventualities but hope none of this will
be needed they say they have the
capability to provide a world-class
Health Service for anyone who needs it
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera Doha